you
yeah I'm going to take off my jacket
okay we might have a few late comers
that they won't interrupt I'll go around
through the back so first of all we'd
like to welcome you to the tune of your
a museum and it's our pride and joy we
hope you enjoy it and we'd like we also
if you want to tour the museum you'll
have to go back out and around and we
have a slide 800 room which might be of
interest to you all especially after you
hear jack
so it's my pleasure to welcome Jack to
the museum for this presentation you're
going to do questions and answers so
he'll be doing Q&A after the speech okay
so welcome jack
thank you for having me and this is a
great venue I suspect its first time
booked TVs ever done one from an
airplane hangar this is my 10th book TV
but the one that's probably closest to
my heart for a variety of reasons and
let me just start with a little
background and many of you know on July
17th 1996 at 8:19 p.m. TWA flight 800
left JFK Airport in New York bound for
Paris 12 min 12 minutes later 831 p.m.
walked the coast of Long Island the
popular South Shore of Long Island it
was blown out of the sky 230 people were
killed 53 of them were TWA employees
many of you in this room knew at least
some of those people there is a memorial
in their honor here at the Peterborough
Museum and if I were coming here just
spread some conspiracy theory I would be
dishonouring their memory and I would be
insulting you instead I'm here to tell
you what happened on the night of July
17th 1996 and the nights and days and
months and years thereafter there are
people in this room would know a whole
lot more of that aviation than I do and
at the end of my conversation I'm going
to take questions and answers because I
know some of you have first-hand
experience with this tragedy
here's what we know in the last few
years researchers have unearthed a
mother lode of new information from of
all places the Central Intelligence
Agency the CIA which raises the
excellent question is what the CIA was
doing involving itself in a domestic
airplane crash we'll get to that in a
minute
and we've also gotten some interesting
videos I and some a lot of
whistleblowers from with inside the
investigation have come forward so the
state of our knowledge today is much
better than was 20 years ago when I say
we I got to give credit to the people
doing a lot of the research here
like my sometimes partner James Sanders
physicists COMSOL cups um you know these
people
Christina bored Jason who came here and
spoke former CBS producer Rael air
former high eastern airline pilot and
United Airlines pilot and alpha
investigator attorney John Clark the
good people at accuracy and media
including Roger Aronoff and Hank used
senior engine SB investigator and others
so they deserve a lot of the credit for
digging up the information I'm going to
share just want to let that be known
since the book comes has come out of
heard from at least a hundred
individuals from within the military or
the aviation industry supporting my
thesis many of them worked for and at
the investigation itself many of them
are still angry about what they
experienced and what happened to them
here's what we know now according to an
air traffic controller in fact this
fella contacted me after the book came
out and he just emailed me today
curiously saying he loved the book and
that he thanked me for treating his
story accurately because I wrote about
him I did not release his name he worked
a 38 years as an air traffic controller
wants to keep his pension he says I have
dependent children and that is you hear
that from a lot of people but what he
told me that night and this is a quote
he said a primary radar return indicated
vertical movement intersecting TWA 800
that's what they saw on their screens at
the TRACON in Westbury and that is what
precipitated the panic in Washington DC
that was the first notice wasn't the
eyewitnesses it came out of the air
traffic control centers in New York that
something had happened to this plane and
the seconds before it intersected that
airplane it disappears and the TWA 800
notation disappears from the screen the
supervisor comes over to my the film my
correspondent and he says have you ever
seen anything like this before
and he said yeah it was they sure do
missile tests wise in the Navy he saw it
all the time so it wasn't something
unknown to him the next day he comes
back in
and he wants to review the tape and he
goes to the supervisor I take another
look at that tape supervisor says no
it's gone it's been taken this is a
violation of all protocol because tape
is supposed to stay there for future
adjudication now the only person who is
spoken about what happens next in
Washington is Richard Clark the former
anti terror czar he's both a liar and a
braggart
so it's hard to sort through his
information and get it the truth but at
least spend some time on this everyone
else who writes about that period of
time in that administration is
completely silent about the event not a
word even though it was the number one
news story in 1996 and it was Richard
Clarke titles the chapter the almost war
of 1996 Clark and I think he's telling
the truth here convenes a meeting of the
his anti terror group in the Situation
Room in the White House at 9 o'clock a
half hour after the crash I know from
Hillary Clinton's logs and from my
sources within the White House that the
Clintons returned to the White House
just about 8:30 after a some routine
fundraiser nearby they've retreated to
the family quarters and there they
stayed for the rest of the night they
did not go down a Situation Room my
florist who was a very good source I
asked him who was with them in the
family quarters he can only come up with
one name I was sandy Berger now Berger I
was the deputy national security adviser
his boss Tony Lake was a national
security adviser and like I said this
elsewhere that he knew that when the
conversation got political he left the
room Berger was the political guy
political decisions were about to be
made among them was the insertion of the
FBI into the investigation one of my
most helpful people on this of
look and he's going to come into the
story later on I'll tell you about it
his name is Vernon gross he was a former
NTSB board member there's only five
members on the National Transportation
Safety Board a pretty powerful position
and Vernon is one of the leading experts
in the country on plane crashes he was
so knowledgeable that CNN called him in
that night to do on-air interpretation
of events on air commentary he spent the
next six hours there and if he tells me
because I wasn't there a couple hours
and already the FBI had taken over the
investigation he goes as a former board
member the NTSB I knew that this was
unprecedented and illegal because the
NTSB was set up to be independent and at
that point they sacrifice their
independence and they yielded to the FBI
now with Vernon gross or no one knew at
that time was that some other insertion
was taking place on that very first day
and this we know from the whole treasure
trove of CIA documents that we've
unearthed and here's what we know
according to their own documents quote
the DI that's the director of
intelligence became involved in the
missile Theory the day after the crash
occurred
the CIA has absolutely no business being
involved in this kind of event
especially since the year before in 1995
the Department of Justice sent out a
memo as often known as the wall' memo
and what that the wall' memo says is
that there's a wall between the
intelligence gatherers in the CIA and
the criminal investigators in the FBI
and never the twain shall meet
they cannot collaborate because it would
be you know of violate people's rights
who knows in George Tenet
in 19 2004 at that point was the
director of Central Intelligence the
head of the CIA and he told the 9/11
Commission that he was first one to
introduce
notion to the public about the wall and
he wasn't the only one who talked about
it but he was the first one to do it
but as the CIA documents prove the CIA
in the FBI for the next 16 months would
collaborate on the TWA investigation
what they do not say outright is that
the collaboration was designed to
subvert the TWA 800 investigation the
CIA had no other role as becomes
incredibly clear when you read their
documents than to make all talk of
missiles go away because on the opening
night that's all people were talking
about within the first few hours we know
that there was one at least one amateur
video taken of the complete a sequence
of events some of you may have seen it
it was aired on MSNBC to best my
knowledge probably two or three times I
talked to one of the fellows who was the
technical director at MSNBC and he said
yeah we showed her a few times in these
three guys in suits games football
copies and told us to keep our mouths
shut or else and that was the end of
that now the best elaboration of what
was seen I got from a 747 pilot and he
was willing to give me his name which
you allow me to use his name which is a
sign of some confidence he was laid up
in a Hong Kong hospital with a back
surgery and his wife came to visit it
and they had nothing to do but watch TV
for several weeks this is during this
whole sequence of events and he said we
watched the video over and over again he
says here's what we see he said there's
a bunch of people milling around on a
deck and then someone says oh look at
the fireworks and then they see and this
is a lot of other people would say the
same thing they see this object come up
off the horizon
it has a red burning tip in a gray
smokey contrail and it's heading out to
sea in an arch over and then I
disappeared for a second and then is a
bright way flash another bright white
flash a big orange fireball and the
plane falls out of the sky he saw this
he said 30 to 50 times
he saw the video Nelson DeMille would
write a novel around this video
nightfall which is worth reading if you
haven't read it so fun now we get into
the CIA documents and they get real
interesting on July 30th thirteen days
after the crash the CIA analyst and I
know the name of the head guy may or may
not mention it later meets with the FBI
and missile team it's only a two or
three man missile team and he headlines
the memo to his superior and all the
names are redacted hold the presses
which is interesting he tells the
superior that he just met with the
missile team the missile team has
already interviewed 144 excellent
eyewitnesses to a missile attack on PW a
flight 800 he says the evidence for a
missile attack for surface air missile
is overwhelming their word he said these
people are mainly professionals and
their testimony is too consistent for it
to be anything but a missile attack now
the CIA analyst brags to his superior
how he discouraged the FBI from going
forward with its report which was just
about ready to be published and he was
successful because that report never
came forward between July 30th and
August 17th
someone gets to the FBI of intending to
do it justice someone gets them before
August 17th because on August 17th the
FBI speaks for the first time to the New
York Times about eyewitnesses now the
FBI would speak almost exclusively with
New York Times New York Times became
very dependent on that relationship in
fact at the heart of this story I'm
telling is a media scandal
more than a government scandal more than
anything else it's a media scandal and
at the heart of the media scandal is in
new york times so they meet with in new
york times and the story is reported on
august 17 so they probably met on the
15th or 16th for about two weeks or so
after the missile team met with the CIA
and the new york times is told that
there are fewer than a dozen credible
eyewitnesses and new york times is
allowed to interview just one of those
eyewitnesses he's a good witness name's
Michael Russell he's on a barge doing
some surveying work
he's pretty knowledgeable and he says
you just see that at the point of his
eye a bright white flash and then he saw
the plane full immediately out of the
sky now that's two things that the NTSB
would later than I happen but at the
time it served the purpose the purpose
then was to switch the scenario from
missile to bomb for whatever reason the
administration decided it could live
with a bomb because a bomb wasn't as
scary as a missile by the way this crash
took place two days before the start of
the Atlanta Olympics so there's a lot at
stake in keeping airlines flying and
keeping you know commercial traffic in
gear keeping people away from feeling
insecure about taking airplanes now in
total the FDA New York Times would
interview let's say before it was
through the FBI would interview 258
eyewitnesses who saw an object streaking
up and hitting the airplane 96 of them
so I come up off the horizon okay and
tracked it all the way up now up those
258 tsunami the New York Times would
interview before the investigation was
over zero I've talked to twenty or
thirty of them I mean they're still
there they still want to tell their
story zero they would speak to not a
single one of the
was 258 official FBI witnesses now 750
people and all gave them reports to the
FBI thousands more sawed because I know
people who chose not to talk to the FBI
and they had good reason as it turned
out the but between the 15th to 17th and
the 23rd the New York Times kept running
more stories about bombs
RDX found on a plane petn found on the
plane myth traces and missiles residue
found outside the plane inside the plane
on the 23rd of August they ran this
headline above the fold right prime
evidence found that the Vice exploded in
Cabin of TWA 800 that's about the polls
in the New York Times prime evidence
found it and they're pointing towards a
bomb but they're not ruling out missile
it exploded in cabin if you degrade
under above-the-fold left
clinton signs welfare reform bill and
eve of democratic national convention
one of those headlines had to go and it
was this one and then the bomb thought
this started going away the day before
the 23rd
I'm sure the Justice Department was
aware that the FBI had been talking too
much so the head of the FBI
investigation Jim Kallstrom is called to
Washington for his first meeting in
Washington heading up this meeting as
best the information suggests is Deputy
Attorney General Jamie Garelick her name
will come back to play in this so keep
track of that her boss is Jenna Reno
Reno was essentially a figurehead she's
Attorney General the Clintons didn't
trust her and trust then they worked
around it just like they worked around
Tony Lake in the National Security
Council it through sandy Berger and
there is no record of what took place on
that meeting on the 22nd but we do know
that all behaviors began to change
immediately afterwards from the 22nd on
there would be no more interviews with
eyewitnesses for
several months and then notice there's a
place later or done hardly for the wrong
reasons we know that on the 23rd
the FAA started searching all over the
world to see if they could find that
they in a place where a to nibble a
flight 800 the plane was used for a dog
training exercise with training aids
explosive training aids it took them
several weeks to find that and then a
series of events began to happen between
the 23rd and 19th of September there is
more scores than a bomb residue and New
York Times didn't know quite what
direction to take partly because the FBI
didn't know what direction to take and
then on September 19th the story
switches to Washington and now it's the
NTSB leading the direction and what they
say is that perhaps it was a mechanical
failure after all it you know they said
a mechanical failure alone might just
explain what happens at 3 to 800 well
this was a problem still because we had
all the all the residue traces of
explosives found over the plane with a
headline find evidence found the bomb
exposed so how do we reconcile these two
well the next day the FBI puts out a
press release that the TWA 800 plane had
been used for a training exercise in st.
Louis six weeks before this happened on
the 21st of September the New York Times
runs an article saying that very same
thing and and basically it kills the
investigation and the people who are
doing the series investigators are
saying of what it's going to be hard for
us to make our case now that that there
was this thing the bomb dog training
exercise sloppy spilled explosives etc
etc by the 21st neither the FBI or the
New York Times had talked to the cop who
did the training the first person in the
media to talk to that cop was me six
years ass
the fact no one had talked to him in
that time and what they decided was that
you know he did his exercise and he's an
African American guy who still as he
told me excuse the language pissed off
to this day about what they did so
because what they did they ruin his
reputation it ruined his reputation
before they even talk to him they
concluded that he is neither too sloppy
exercise his Filton training aids over
the plane and those are what accounts
for the explosive residues they were
found on the plane when the stuff that
was found on the wing you know Carlo his
dog was not capable of getting out there
and building that but that didn't matter
or was it something's under curtain
separating the back in front
now that's and matter they just went
with it here's what they could have
found out with an hour's worth of
investigation york times have known this
the FBI all that this cop told I put on
his report was the time of the exercise
and white body so weave into an exercise
on a 747 on June 20th and sing oh it's
on a wide-body
and he did it from 10:45 to 12:15 p.m.
here's what the FBI knew it at 12:30 the
750 to 800 degree hundred plane left the
gate with the T FBI did not say is that
there are 400 people on board and they
were bound for Hawaii now as some of you
who's worked on loading international
flights no you can't do that in 15
minutes
the cop that is exercised on a
completely sterile plane there was no
one on board his plane for the whole
time he did the exercises if they could
have they could prove that in an hour
and it's easily proved that there's no
now you can't even dispute it that's
playing that's at 12:35 400 people
stopped what we're ready to go to
Honolulu and they were supposed to
believe that in a 20 min exercise
20-minute period in an hour-and-a-half
exercise it just doesn't make any sense
then there's other problems with it are
obvious the aides he used in no way
the composition of the residue found on
the plane nor does it match where they
placed it
the place was wrong the compositions
wrong the planes wrong it was a total
lie that there's no euphemism to
disguise what they did and they
sacrificed this guy's career to get it
done and he's still humiliated to this
day he got letters from the FDA
condemning him etc and had to live with
this but that was the cover they needed
that was all the cover they needed now
from that point on from September 21st a
second on the government moved into a
fully different mode and that was the
mechanical failure mode and some of you
are around to remember that I've talked
a lot of PWA people who were who
remember them like getting punched in
his stomach when they heard that I
especially the people who work in fuel
tanks because the fuel tank people would
be have to bear the brunt of that story
that there is something wrong with the
fuel tank and it blew up
well in fact when I get emails from
people reading the book the fuel tank
before the anger is I will tell you that
the at that point to the NTSB had been
totally shut out of witness review they
were supposed to would do the interviews
our witnesses they're supposed to review
the statements they were totally shut
out like they're humiliated they're sent
home yes I wouldn't even let them look
at the interviews after the FBI is done
them instead the FBI handed the
interviews over to the CIA who else to
examine interviews and to decide what it
is that the eyewitnesses saw they have
absolutely no experience in this they
had not only no experience we have no
legal justification for this now the FBI
wasn't eager to do this you could see
that so when they gave them the CIA the
witness statements in small doses and in
time they only gave them finally one
third of the total eyewitness statements
I don't know why does the third but
they're only working from a third of
them didn't matter
on December 31st 1996 the CIA analyst
named Randolph
by the way Randolph he wants to give me
a call sometime comes to the conclusion
that all he needs to do to explain what
these people saw is contained within the
one plane itself it's always always
flight 800 he decides that the nose of
the plane was blown off then the plane
tilted almost 90 degrees up right about
70 or 80 degrees and then noseless and
people hate the engine room know how
would a [ __ ] in a frock this is it shot
up about four thousand feet and then and
of course of that deceive people into
thinking they were seeing a missile now
I talked to many many aviators natives
hit their head when they saw that and so
this is not this can happen and it said
so they went from 13,000 something feeds
to 17,000 plus feet and he said that's
what confused them now we'll get back to
that in a second because it becomes a
they they're also contracted with
creating a video to show that and that
was what they would close the case now
we know that that happened on December
31st by February 1997 I George Tenet has
now been promoted to the director of
Central Intelligence he's a political
guy to even the number two guy when this
all started they fired the number one
guy John Deutsche promote tenant he
signs off on it yeah that's what it was
knows the plane falls off shoots up
right sends a letter Louis Freeh this is
what it is then one heroic character
from the FBI stands up and I've
identified this guy by name I'm not sure
what I should mention it's tonight foot
he's the basically the head of it now -
man missile team the fact that there's
only two men on the FBI missile team
tells you something but on April 29 1997
he meets with the CIA and he says I
don't buy this for a moment he says we
have at least 30 eyewitnesses who sell
saw the object coming in the opposite
direction here doing so it could have
been TWA and crippled flight that they
saw he said we have at least eight
eyewitnesses who saw them this
hit the airplane we said all the radar
data totally disagrees with you're
trying to sell us because I insist that
you go back to the drawing board and and
start over because this this I won't buy
this I don't buy this now the other
member of the missile team apparently
according to CIA analyst was okay with
the CIA this one guy refused Mazda dude
I'm gonna name him named Steve Bongard
trying to touch him reach him see if
you're listening get in touch
he then and I don't think he knew this
until recently on that same April 29th
1997 day that he's fighting with the CIA
either in Washington or New York he ends
up in North Carolina and we on paper he
does interviewing one of the key
eyewitnesses in this book and this story
is witness number 73 I start out the
book with the story witness 73 some of
you read this and here's I just replayed
the story a little bit on them in 2009
in summer 2009 I get a call out of blue
and she goes
Jack Castle I said yeah she goes this is
witness 73 you know I am I said yes I do
I said upside down Nike swoosh right she
goes that's me here's the story and the
FBI writes out these which are called
302s mr. witness summaries and here's
what the FBI's witness summary from July
20th 1996 says about their interview
with witness number 73 I'm going to call
her Cindy just give her name it's a name
I give her the book it's not a real name
so they're talking to sandy sandy tells
them she's on the beach with two of her
in-laws and she sees and she's a
aviation she's interest in aviation
because she's a travel professional
she's tracking flight 800 to come across
the sky this is awfully low considering
how far was that at JFK and she was
right because it held the altitude down
for innocent reasons and then she says
that she decided to come up the horizon
and it has a you know a red tip smoky
contrail it comes up you're watching it
hard and zigzag
this is BAM exposed right outside of the
right wing BAM another explosion then
she said I see the nose of the plane
come off you know and then she said
stalls and falls right out of the sky
breaks into flames into an iron fireball
now three days after the crash sandy had
explained and told the FBI the break-up
sequence of that aircraft with the nose
coming off first before anyone knew it
would take them weeks to map at the
debris field before they could validate
what you had said but no one saw it more
clearly than she did and she cooperated
fully with the FBI three days later and
her two in-laws had wanted nothing to do
with it her husband who wasn't with her
I almost you know broke off their
engagement they're engaged at that time
because she talked to the FBI me they
were the N ones were really upset that
she gave them their names with their
refuse to talk they saw what she did uh
maybe they had good reason on April 29th
1997 the same day that Steve bond guard
is protesting to the CIA in Washington
or New York
he's down in North Carolina interviewing
probably unknown to him
sandy same day because the CIA said Oh
we'll take care of that yeah they took
care of it they put in a new 302 into
her five okay and here's what sandy told
me when we talked in 2009 she goes
because I asked her I said tell me about
the second interview she goes all you
just like you don't know about that and
I said what she goes well and the second
interview I see you just found out about
it she said it said I had several Long
Island iced tea cocktails that night and
I said and she goes I don't even know
what a Long Island iced tea is and I
said could it have been another drink
she said no I said had any sure she goes
no I don't drink at all and then I said
then she said there's something you
don't know I said what's that she goes
there was no second interview the CIA
had fully manufactured a second
interview that same day it's in the gate
her Testament on the same day that the
FBI had an a missile team gave them
grief about what they were doing and
then it's something I said
to her there's something you don't know
so there was that I said you're not the
only one
hey I'll explain they did that to
several key eyewitnesses that is create
manufacturer out of whole cloth fully
new witness statements to justify the
theory they were trying to sell in a
later meeting and this was made public
stat about 1999 with the NTSB the CIA
analyst conceded that only one witness
had actually reported seeing the
crippled plane with a nose to mouth line
and he was the man under bridge and I've
got another minute on bridge pretty well
and his wife's a great characters names
my choir works on a Philadelphia's mill
right and when they closed the case with
the FBI in November 1997 they showed for
one time and many of you have seen this
the animation showing the plane flying
along those blows off spontaneously fuel
tank explosion guys work and fuel thanks
you guys a better job in picture and a
plane shoots up three four thousand feet
confuses the eyewitnesses the eyewitness
has been obviously a missile it sounds
like a Soviet propaganda if you ever
seen that the language in it the
graphics and they tilt it all around
they finally conceded that the NTSB some
years later around the testimony of this
one man my choir the man on the bridge
and it turns out of course that they
based it on a second interview with my
choir because in his first interview he
says exactly what sandy said yeah I saw
the thing come up off the beach from the
lodge Park Laurel Manila boo boo boo boo
and the second is because I didn't take
him up the beach I saw at about 20
degrees off the rise when I first saw it
yeah it could have been sighted on
during a critical flight of course right
he just made that up and put it into the
record there was no second interview
with my choir there was no second
interview with Sandy fellow who was a
flying above it was a Navy guy with real
missile experience and everything so
Adam is out of his plane is the US
airplane and they made up a new
interview for him because in his thing
he said I saw a missile going from right
to left no one makes it on a thing and
his second new 302 no he saw it going
from left to right less than flight 800
right they did this release three that
we know of there probably more but these
are the ones we've been able to prove
and finally going through CIA documents
we just found the year or so ago we find
out that they say this is a quote that
amount some calculated attitude altitude
Fortuna to 800 post-explosion was 14,500
feet
they knew that not to 17,000 plus feet
they sold to the American people they
showed that video once when the FBI
closed the case in November and no one
in the media even asked what's the CIA
doing here let alone is this stuff is
not how can you possibly be trying to
sell us this now then another I Jane
Sanders who work with me on one previous
book and it was the Earl for the
earliest explorer honest calls me one
day about a year ago goes jack you won't
believe what happened they just sent me
the video and I said v video you know he
goes Jim have been sending Freedom of
Information Act request to the FBI for
some time and when we get it and we look
at it we realize it is not the video
from July 17th but it's almost as useful
it's a video we knew about from July
12th 1996 and it was a video shot in the
south coast of Long Island by an amateur
we knew it existed because both the FBI
and the CIA talked about it but it was a
video of an apparent missile test the
Defense Intelligence Agency had reviewed
the video early on and said yeah this is
a surface their missile we're looking at
and they talked about the smoke trail
going up blah blah blah well when we saw
the video we realized it was more than
smoke trail coming up we saw the flaming
debris coming down this is five days
before PWA flight 800 went down the
south coast of Long Island an obvious
missile test taking place now that
wouldn't matter a whole lot except when
the FBI closed this case in November
1997 they said there had been no missile
test in the area for at least two years
they know that this happened they knew
about this video they did not enter that
video into evidence and from the CIA
documents we also know that many
eyewitnesses saw would it look like a
missile test on July 7 1996 so you have
July 7th we have July 12th we have to be
July 17th you don't have to be a math
major to see the sequence here every
five days after my book came out I heard
from other people who said you know I
don't just matters that on July 7th I
was camping you know and I saw this yeah
it does matter because that was that was
what was going on now the from 19
November 1997 on the case is basically
closed the NTSB held two hearings no
eyewitnesses were allowed to testify
first time ever totally unprecedented
the basically they get away with no
successful cover-up in American
peacetime history the great untold story
of our time and 53 of your colleagues
died without justice being brought to
their members and their families now I'm
going to jump ahead a little bit now I'm
gonna take some questions and answers
hearing add some other little useful
anecdotes but the Deputy Attorney
General who oversaw this investigation
Jamie Garelick in May of 1997 after this
is essentially put to bed gets a new job
despite the fact there is no experience
in either mortgage or finance she
Nations named vice chairman of Fannie
Mae
in the next five and a half years next
six years she'll make twenty five
million dollars as vice chairman of
fannie mae and then a burst of
patriotism she stopped steps down to
take one of five democratic positions on
the 9/11 Commission so she is basically
overseeing the events leading up to
September 11th in April 2004 Attorney
General John Ashcroft testifies the 9/11
Commission and he says this is a quote
the single greatest structural clause
for September 11th was the wall this is
the wall memo that prevented the CIA and
the FBI from speaking to each other I
should note that speed Bongard the head
of the FBI missile team and I mentioned
protested loudly about the wall in the
run-up to September 11 and he went
public with this process and because
there was a terrorist afoot and America
said and we can't look for him because
we're the investigators as an
intelligence issue because this is not
well two weeks after he says that he
goes people are going to die two weeks
later
this fellow joins 18 of his buddies and
they hijack the four planes and fill
3,000 people because of the wall and so
full disclosure Ashcroft continues
compels me to inform you that the author
the wall memorandum is a member of this
commission the author of that wall memo
was ms Jamie Garelick so as the nation
learned in the aftermath of 9/11 the
wall that was breached also easily to
protect the secrets of TWA 800 held all
too firmly when it came to protecting
the security of the United States and
that's where we are today now I'm going
to close with one last anecdote because
it's a sort of lighter fun anecdote and
then we'll take some questions and when
we take questions by the way if you
could speak up because we're just
picking up the end
noise in early july of this year
accuracy and media agra excellent
organization of Washington hosted a
press conference at the National Press
Club on TWA flight 800 they invited me
to speak and I talked to Vernon gross
the NTSB board member the night before
and excuse me I start clapping it by the
way it's just ignore it no them me so
Vernon I didn't even know he lived in
Washington right so want you from Nana
fresco and you know and check it out so
he comes down and then we invite him up
to speak and he speaks for about 10
minutes and then he says to me
afterwards he goes by the way tomorrow
I'm having lunch with the chairman of
the National Transportation Safety Board
you know he said you want to come yeah
sure
well so I go to lunch and I meet the new
chairman in the National Transportation
Safety Board his name Christopher Hart
and I'm looking for a point of
connection with Christopher Hart and I'm
trying not to push my book Vernon is but
I'm not I'm just laying back trying to
convince him that I'm saying and this is
the story that's worth looking at and
then I realized what it was he he
mentioned that he had been on the board
between 1989 and 1992 when Clinton
replaced him now
what was interesting about that is I've
written about that in the book but I
know her heart was I don't know anything
about his background other than that he
had an arrow arrow physics degree from
Princeton a law degree from Harvard it
was instrument-rated pilot and as the
Washington Post pointed at at the time
he was replaced by Jim Hall who was a
whose best qualification was his
driver's license right this is what the
Washington Post said at the time and I
said I said I wrote about that in my
book and he said I posted that on my
wall the article from the Washington
Post well here are two things I didn't
know about Christopher harden Ximena
one instant he was democrat so he
replaced a Democrat with a Democrat he
replaced a Democrat with extraordinary
credentials with one with no credentials
the other thing is this is an African
American right so to replace a black
Democrat with a white hat Democrat is an
act of the foresight of the Clinton
administration to pack these boards with
people who are going to come in handy
well he adds two more people before 1996
both of them political operatives so by
the time 1996 comes Jim Hall is now the
chairman and you have three of the five
board members and so when the FBI
illegally takes over the investigation
they just roll over
thank you yeah and they watched it all
happen and that's what I found that so
any of that that's how clever in a sense
and this was and what was otherwise a
sort of awkward improvised cover-up that
was done essentially just to kick that
can down a road past November and hope
for the best and they've kicked in now
for twenty years and let's hope they can
stop kicking a little help from book TV
so thank you very much and I appreciate
your coming today
now questions I just speak up okay -
stand up - if you don't mind if you can
take any seat belts and I would say you
know when I started this investigation I
you know a certain thing called
confirmation bias you know you you see a
set of facts and you want them to
confirm what you hope will be the
outcome well when I first got into this
in the year 2000 I hope the outcome
would be terrorists I would just feel
more comfortable with that because I
remember when Pierre Salinger came
forward and saying was a navy I said it
can't be a navy I definitely the most
unpatriotic of him to say that well
unfortunately the evidence
overwhelmingly points the naval
involvement on the night of July 17 now
there may have been some rogue element
to snuck in there that may have been an
allied ship in the maneuvers I don't
know I do not know literally who fired
the missile but I know that missiles
were fired and I know that missiles took
down flight 800 the evidence
overwhelmingly argues for navy
involvement and The Smoking Gun was
there from the beginning and that is
that what everyone acknowledged except
for the New York Times which chose not
to acknowledge anything of essence there
was a Navy p3 Orion hovering right above
TWA flight 800 when it blew up now at
the time their technical manuals easily
available I went back and found them and
which cp3 is used as the communications
mode and what's called a cooperative
engagement capability where various
ships and submarines cooperate to do a
missile test and shoot other missiles at
a sky shoot planes out of the sky and it
was sitting right there we also know
that the weather ships in the area
finally at least three submarines in one
Cruiser so we know that was they were
there we know that now who fired what I
do not know but yes Navy was there
I know integrator in your book you
mentioned three subtle yes that your
pain wildin in the other / yes there was
an article article came out on the
internet which I don't trust a minute
surely it
Leyton said that the missile that was
hired was hired by the seal yet which
was not healing commission until a year
and two days after the accident that's
right no and I've seen that report it
has the ring of credibility to it I've
tried to check it out because they're a
couple names mentioned who were on the
sea wolf and I've tried to contact those
people and guess what they don't return
my phone calls
yeah I I wouldn't rule that out that was
not mentioned as being right the FBI
conceded there were three submarines the
ones you mentioned then the the USS
Normandy in the immediate vicinity of
the crash we also know that from day one
the Navy was lying to the FBI the Navy
never came forward these Christine
aboard Jason who spoke here was witness
to one incident where someone asked why
is the Navy involved in its
investigation when the Navy may be the
culprit and they what they did is they
picked up the sky and they hustled them
right out of the room you know yeah yeah
I've got at least two eyewitnesses for
that so that said I just have the Navy
would not have and could not have
covered this up on its own it had to
come from above
yes sir Lodi both an accident you know
Yeah right here a lot of people have
asked me was there anyone on that plane
who deserved his/her own missile and the
answer is no no they would not shoot
that the US Navy would not shoot down
one of our own aircraft - but we know
that in 1988 and the US Navy did shoot
down an Iranian Airbus the passenger
plane so accidents going to happen well
I would say the reluctance to admit it
had a lot to do with the election 1996
how could the Navy wasn't going to
picnic make them - kept this under wraps
they might have fudged a little but yeah
and then we're going to keep under wraps
and that's her happy
Crisco - works in detail I was reading
the time I read that a doctor for the
autopsy found that a large amount it's
ethically
those people see Indonesia which is for
justice left calf simply he found large
amounts
shrapnel and much of asbestos positive
for
solid rocket fuel health and thoughts on
how that was covered up or what life
they're going on married is also the
author well you know the those of you
who saw Christina Borges in here in in
July she wrote and directed a
documentary with Thomas walk-up called
TWA flight 800 which is excellent came
out three years ago and to the Cubs to
the people who had at least a half a
dozen high-level whistleblowers
participate
two of them were the pathologist's and
when I was watching that I thought you
could have made a separate documentary
and it would be a gruesome one on what
happened to the bodies because in a fuel
tank explosion they're going to burn
it's going to be ugly but they're going
to burn but in this case they were in
some cases the DNA refused from one body
into another there are pieces of bone
flying around like arrowheads you know
sticking into the side of the fuselage
and they showed some of this on these
guys going to have pretty tough stomachs
to do this but yeah the the injuries
were not at all consistent with the fuel
tank fire at least to those that were in
the place where the explosive devices
were most damaging yeah good question
yes ma'am
now the great report of the wreckage was
reassembled and at the Calverton hangar
and Long Island where they did the
investigation and now it has been since
then shipped to the NTSB training
facility in Virginia and it's used as
sort of like a dumb show for people when
they walk them through and say see you
know it's no holes here now a missile
struck here you know it's you know it's
as if it's uses very questionable Mike
did you point out this is on the first
murder on a shutdown by Canadian
historian I thought was 91 to 88 did he
wake up who shot down a Iranian airliner
that mini golf or with some traffic and
the captain testified definitely of
aircraft narrator on page one was
diamond turning accelerating for his
ship he gave the command to fire okay
this area but unfortunately said my
proverb of black Peter before everything
and there's no no memory here on 22,000
feet in Middle earth airway 11 o'clock
well the main edges crow I'm just acting
on emotion but it
oh I understand we have to say that a
lot popular result in a statement and if
no one will see the satellite day event
you know about it yeah there was a there
are legs we three satellites that had
flight 800 in its view one of the
parents from Pennsylvania whose daughter
was killed in a crash there is a French
a group of French students like 15 of
them who went to we're going to Paris
tonight
he used his as a family member he was
allowed a certain leeway and he got to
talk to them said there were three eyes
satellites of that night and they were
all malfunctioning this was both and
that's literally what he was told and so
no there's never been anything seen from
that and yet when the CIA created its
animation of the zoom climb with a nose
falling off a plane shooting up they
claimed that infrared sensors on u.s.
satellite blah blah blah but they've
never shown in the images they just was
talking out of school it didn't show
anything like that yes
a lot of great people yeah I know I
[ __ ] a lot of angry to bury people
about this one but let me talk about
Boeing first a Boeing in TWA took the
fall basically and then you say why
would they do that well in Boeing his
case was pretty obvious they were in the
middle of a merger talk with McDonnell
Douglas which would given him
essentially a 100 percent lock on the
American commercial airline market in
the same week that the and this was at
that time exactly the time in the same
week that the Department of Justice
approved that merger the they turned
down a merger between Office Depot and
staples which was given them a six
percent lock on the crucial office
supply market so make the Boeing if they
wanted to survive
really than that much choice a TWA I've
heard a lot of stories about why each
and every way went along and you know
probably not good place to go into them
all right now but afterwards we Montauk
because uh I took this many many t
degree people have their theories but
anyhow the for a lot of people think it
was the death knell of the airline and
four years later would be out of
business and merging the with American
Airlines Allie's for some unhappy short
period and then moving on but yeah it's
unfortunate yes sir
I heard about this before
answer your questions that Christina why
don't you hand you a piece of P that one
slide head look at they with the rest of
here it's all round up and what precise
she show larger large hoppers and then I
think they had second thoughts and they
took it down to Virginia and
reconstructed it family yeah yeah I'm a
fever small piece right well
I worked on
a57
I remember mediately after they this one
well it will cost on the outside of wine
no water no coughs not everybody crying
yeah yeah I'll just rip this off then we
knew that a lot
Cohen and again at the end of the day
after four years they the spark that
sets off the fuel tank is of unknown
origin right the overheated then the
overheating of the center fuel thanks
for sitting on the runway it's afk is 71
degrees
please plane sit on runways in Cairo and
Phoenix you know they send all the time
to care office
you have a slope oh it did explode I
mean some yeah some seconds after the
whole plane caught fire and why not you
know yeah
aha
why the fire
tell you right now for your flex
advantage in believe they help you told
ya fine I've heard that story uh yeah
I've heard that story several times in
it in fact Nelson DeMille does anyone
read nightfall his book which is really
a very good rule little steamy opening
chapter and I get beyond that but I just
listened to it driving back cross
country and it's it's for it's a lot of
fun it's about it's based around the
missing video and he comes to the same
conclusion that I did basically but he
was deeply involved in research Long
Island for some of his other books and
he knew a lot of FBI agents and every
time he ran into one he'd get that same
Stonewall you know he said now the NY
APB or the Suffolk County police would
be much more forthcoming with the FBI it
was the fuel tank explosion you know I
mean they I mean they stick to their
they've gotten their marching orders and
they do it and that the fellow in the
missile team that I referred to earlier
he did his twenty years and got out and
I think that's because there's for
certain people that kind of culture is a
very difficult to buy when something's
going wrong in the back yes sir
so the doubles aircraft in long beach
tourism in New Year befall the full
night is coming in the lectures so all
we said another topic joined the TV
ratings you a few years back and with
something but we made on them and I said
you know people can simulate these TT
break me up and no plan I'm telling you
that means shot down he was no doubt on
and you wouldn't need I've been with
moving back to and I can tell you to
talk about employing people the engineer
definitely shot down from Amanda now at
the same time also said of your video or
the church step now will you see the
classic line on 911 I'm time well we
talked about many people that in talks
about how when people a shot down oops I
mean yeah and precision when
administration so this is my statement
was the color up that you know we're
talking about is like so nasty are many
girls believe we're talking about
yeah the ATC guys see a people putting
us
spiral denier types of docketed by our
university if importance on normal
center center right so when you look at
all of this we do all the time all the
subcategory in the same time looking at
cutting tournament you know the FBI CIA
military people is not their favorite
cast members we keep the draft dodger
why would they protection so with all
that look at this book we can look at
them to your interest and it's framed up
but my customers do this with all of the
massive work that it took to do as much
as they dislike clinton military in CIA
and the question how would want to be
protective of i would encourage us to
you know we screwed up we're going to
write a check we messed up what we're
gonna follow through that but in order
to show
now in fact that there's so much for
personally or some linear claim you
missed out we have missile just going on
from there never been able to walk you
know and i will die here's my best
answer is that on the night of july 17th
1996 they panicked and then they decided
to kick this can down the road and once
you start kicking it you can't kick it
back then then what you're doing is
you're covering for yourself and and
despite all the people who seem to be
involved I don't think there's other
than a couple people in the Navy I don't
think there's a six to ten civilians who
really know what happened that night
and here's here's what they share with
us Stephanopoulos you're right talks
about it accidentally on 9/11 right he
writes a book about it he writes a book
he doesn't even mention the incident
George Tenet
who is the head of dead you know who
oversaw the cover-up from the CIA
position writes a book doesn't mention
it Leon Panetta is the one who alerts
Clinton doesn't mention it
Bill Clinton writes a 900-page book one
paragraph
Hillary Clinton 500 page book one-third
of a sentence I Louie free head of the
FBI at the time
two sentences I mean then the Senate
Select Committee on Intelligence which
covers all of those matters certainly
everything that's involved with the CIA
from 1996 to 97 doesn't mention it it's
a conspiracy of silence they've kicked
it down the memory hole my hope and this
is bizarre I'm going to put that appeal
right now is I think the one person of
conscience and all of this who suffered
most from having to live with this it
was the head of the FBI investigation
Jim Kallstrom who's now on Fox as their
terrorist go-to guy which means Fox
won't talk about this but I know he's
tortured
I know family members who've come up to
him in his face and said you're lying
and he's the public face of this
investigation
and if anyone I think has an interest in
coming forward and just clearing the air
I think would be he and what I would
recommend because who arrests who at
this point I would say what you need is
like a South Africa style Truth and
Reconciliation Commission where you just
okay we're going to waive all punishment
and let's just sort out the facts and
hope this doesn't happen again
yes sir interesting colors working out
I've been in a Jamaican since 1988 with
several airlines here in Kansas the area
started out as a airplane electrician in
the l-1011 fill tanks replacing the
hiring supervision management on the
whole line I'm going to safety now that
front of the house but do all of us talk
about picking the pan along we're still
kicking the pan we have a terrible
burden degree for those who've lost
loved ones we have a terrible financial
burden with this now we're still
following this can down the road trying
to keep feel tension exploding that
don't explode right now here in Kansas
City
we're installing inert gas systems that
are it's usually expensive on every
single aircraft across the board you
know if you just like to say this
reconciliation what is it look stop and
we're just pouring money
you know I resources down this hole and
you know and what happened as you know
is that immediately after his crash had
this had they really thought it's a fuel
tank explosion it would have ground at
old 747 certainly Air Force One which is
a 747 but that didn't happen
yeah they grounded seven three sevens
and said you got to look at everything
in your tank all your wiring we pull off
we said you know what we're just going
to pull all the wiring we ground our
hopefully pull the wiring out the
leading edges all all that we found one
wire and these were old two hundred
bases opens up three sevens we found one
wire our leader we had 1977 side one
wire that had one spot it was aged and
it was in a continent on the outside the
front spar you would think that you
would find some mechanical some
electrical problem I have yet to see one
in all of these years and that's why at
the end of the investigation for the
NTSB they simply concluded up you know
must minute of unknown origin you know
they don't know where that spark came
from and then we found out by the way
from the CIA documents that their head
of their of their the witness team at
the time the guy named David Maher I was
working with the CIA he worked with him
for 16 months but the NTSB is working
with the CIA I mean they had your people
in the NTSB who were problematic most of
the people by the way 99 percent of the
people involved investigation we're
doing the right thing or trying to
including most of the FBI but there are
few people in key positions who weren't
and they just allow things to happen
when you meet when you you know my
effect I was just talking to this air
traffic controls I mentioned earlier
just email me today and he said you're
right he goes you know you were right to
mention pensions he goes because I said
the the word pension is like you know
for us with word America is in Sicily I
mean a guarantee silence people he said
but I worked 30 years as an air traffic
controller so they take that away from
me I'm finished you know and that has a
for the people work in and around
government as a great silencer also what
happens as so many of these people end
up working for defense contractors and
then if they go public they not only
risk their pensions and their freedom
but they risk their whole company's
connections with the government and so
there's a lot of low-level fear among
people who know stuff
and and like I say there's only a
handful of I've always say bad people
involved but a lot of people just just
afraid to speak out yes sir the captain
of the Coast Guard boat I do not know
about that there is a I will say that
there was just one one angle of the
story we have not talked about is this
is that on the night of July 17th 1996
of Coast Guard went out there as did a
lot of like this commercial fishermen
and private yachts men and stuff and
many of them heard the distinctive
paying from the black boxes the flight
data recorder cockpit voice recorder
there actually orange boxes you know but
there and so it was only 120 feet of
water was calm they you know other than
the bodies this is the first thing that
gets picked up it took them a week to
retrieve them during that week they were
putting out various stories oh they must
be damaged and must be buried and I've
seen the video of the actual Navy divers
finding them and it's like finding a
Hasek in your living room I mean it's
just sitting there on the floor big
orange box they pick it up oh I mean and
they were innocent they just picked up
saying well we found we found them I am
and because and then when they tested
them of course they revealed nothing and
then one of the family members was able
to bring in an audio expert and he said
yeah with the final seconds of it edited
out and the NTSB didn't even disagree
with that I swear they're just missing
it's one of those things that are
missing like 116 pieces of the plane
they were sent to the FBI lab and never
seen again
so so many things were subtracted
deleted removed stolen covered up
destroyed but the one thing they could
not silence were the eyewitnesses and
they were the most critical part of this
testimony and they are continuing to
speak out to this day why don't we take
one more question and I think we
probably better wrap it up here for you
guys milk
I guess right any other questions yes
Michael what is this about question
judgment when they treat captain
certification because he hated that
picture to keep the or invisible faculty
that submits a underclass and Terry did
that and the analyzed resident it was
mr. president and all the other a miss
residence and when the FBI after
interrogation setting the prison glasses
widely encountered ran for 18 long time
we have certainly a salty positive whose
husband rustles a thread Canon stated
here in federal critical who Lewis
evidence of a crime and they just was
dessert until now over his because they
did what that word missile every
initially came and anybody might ever
ever kid prudent wasn't this one person
ages but that maketh this is
shame they investigation from day one
and in fact that's what got me started
is four years after the crash I met
James and Elizabeth Sanders who came to
Kansas City and speak to large TWA group
and you're right
Sanders investigative reporter Terry
Stacy was the 747 manager and pilot
working at the investigation and the
first and what happened is in and Liz
Sanders was a TWA trainer and 5330 where
employees were killed in a crash she
knew a lot of them who trained a lot of
them and she was heartbroken she was
gone from one memorial service to
another she runs in this Stacy and Stacy
says her hey is your husband still an
investigative reporter and she says yes
he goes have him talk to me so Stacy and
Sanders get together and the first thing
Stacy tells Sanders is there's a
cover-up going on and so they started
collaborating to get information out of
the investigation into the mainstream
and one thing that Stacy told Sanders is
about was this orange residue on the
seat bags and one certain section of the
plane Sanders asked them to scrape off
the residue it doesn't scrape so he
takes a pinch of foam rubber puts it in
a FedEx envelope sends it to Sanders
Sanders as it tested goes public with
the results as a result of that Stacy
Sanders and Elizabeth Sanders are
hounded finally arrested Elizabeth and
James are tried and convicted in a
federal court of conspiracy to steal
airplane parts and not a single person
and the media raise this as a First
Amendment issue and when I heard that
story that's when I said maybe I better
get involved in it so I want to thank
you all for coming out it's a excellent
crew
[Applause]
books over there I appreciate it in
going to stick around later and ask
questions and I will say this by the way
if you know anyone who has information
haven't go to my website Castle calm and
softly communicate through that okay
appreciate it